One week from today, we are releasing the
newest shirt in our Artist Series over at
microcosmos.store.
Previously, we’ve made shirts that you can
wear to show your love for tardigrades and
hydra, and now it  is time to show our appreciation
for the algae that produces almost half of
the air that we breathe.
That’s right, our little golden friend the
diatom is getting its own shirt, designed
by Josh Quick, and it will be available for
pre-order next Monday, February 6th at microcosmos.store!
Science is built on questions.
So let’s start today with a question: what do you
think happens when you set off an electrical
spark in the microcosmos…
maybe something like this little fireworks
show that James, our master of microscopes,
set off with a short circuit?
Perhaps your mind immediately jumps to something
destructive, you've got painful
shocks that tear things apart.
That fits some of what's happening here.
The spark James created was strong enough
to chip the glass slide.
It was also strong enough to break the bonds
between hydrogen and oxygen in the water,
a process called electrolysis.
We can’t see those individual atoms separating
from each other, but we can see the end result:
hydrogen and oxygen bubbles that build and
burst in front of our eyes.
Or maybe you think that electricity
is more of a productive force,
something that creates instead of breaks.
And that too fits some of what we see here.
That same electricity that broke apart water
molecules also created a world of charged
particles, painting an otherworldly landscape
in the process.
You may also be a fan of a third option: chaos.
Your mind replays images of frog legs zapping
to life or hair defying gravity as electricity
flows through limbs.
The answer, honestly, might—ahem—shock
you.
It was certainly not what I would have expected.
So what happens when you apply an electric
field to the microcosmos?
Order.
Watch as this whirlwind of ciliate activity
un-whirlwinds itself, abruptly shifting to
a uniform direction of movement as if someone
whipped out a bullhorn and yelled at them
to get in line.
Of course, there is no invisible person with
a bullhorn.
There is just James, and a power supply that
he used to create an electric field across
the slide.
The movement that the ciliates are showing
is a particular form of motion called “galvanotaxis,”
though you might also hear it called “electrotaxis.”
Many organisms exhibit galvanotaxis of some
kind—even our own cells are capable of it.
But today, we’re focusing on a favorite
group of organisms.
Our fuzzy, single-celled eukaryotic friends:
the ciliates.
(Though we caveat that not
all ciliates behave this way).
Galvanotaxis has been particularly well-studied
in paramecium, and the ciliates we’re watching
today behave in a similar way.
But ciliates are vast and diverse.
And we’ve watched ciliates of all sorts
change their motion in response to different
types of stimuli.
We’ve seen them direct themselves in the
direction of chemical gradients, a form of
motion called chemotaxis.
We’ve also watched as some species either
seek out light like moths, or shun it like vampires.
Those ciliates are showing a form of light-directed
motion called phototaxis.
Galvanotaxis is sort of like these forms of
motion in that the cells are reacting to something
in the environment around them.
For chemotaxis and phototaxis, those “something’s”
are chemicals and light.
For galvanotaxis, it’s a shift in the electric
potential that changes the flow of ions and
particles both around and within the organisms.
But for ciliates, galvanotaxis is also fundamentally
different from those two other forms of motion.
Chemotaxis and phototaxis are both behaviors
that give ciliates some kind of benefit in the end.
It can steer them towards food or light for
photosynthesis, or away from threats like
predators and UV damage.
Galvanotaxis doesn’t steer ciliates to any
obvious purpose or advantage.
It is just something that happens, a function
of the way that ciliates themselves are built,
not something that was selected for by evolution
through natural selection.
There is a whole sequence of events based
on electrochemistry that drive how this happens.
It starts with an electric field, which creates
a voltage gradient across the microcosmos.
This gradient interacts with the body of the
ciliates, creating differences between the
interior and the exterior of the cell that
cause calcium and potassium ions to flow across
the membrane.
That is the part scientists understand.
The part that happens next is a bit more mysterious.
That flow of ions changes the movement of
the ciliate’s cilia—those hair-like structures
that whip back and forth to propel the organism
around the microcosmos.
At the front end of the cell, the flow of
ions causes the cilia to beat more frequently,
a movement called ciliary augmentation.
Meanwhile, at the other end, the flow of ions
causes the cilia to beat more frequently as
well, but in the opposite direction, which
is called ciliary reversal.
For the ciliate, the opposing motions of its
cilia creates a torque that ultimately directs
the organism towards the cathode.
The result, as we see over and over again
in our samples, is order.
The changes in ciliary motion that drive this
behavior is called the Ludloff phenomenon,
named for the 19th century scientist Karl
Ludloff who described its occurrence in paramecium.
At the time, he thought the movement was simply
a result of electromagnetic interactions with
the cilia, but research since then has revealed
the underlying physiology of the cell itself
that makes this happen.
And as we’ve said, this is—as far as we
can tell—simply a function of how these
ciliates are built, a consequence of electrochemistry
and electrophysiology that combines into something
that happens, with no purpose or advantage.
In fact, for some ciliates, this leads to
a tragic end as they get too close to the
electrodes that inadvertently controlled them.
But that does not mean galvanotaxis is function-less.
For James, a careful application of electricity
to his samples has become a valuable tool,
helping him dig up microbes that are hidden
in his mud samples.
And our own bodies even
are testament to the fact
that galvanotaxis can be
an incredibly powerful instructor.
It directs the development of embryos, repairs
our wounds, and helps grow our nerve cells.
It’s just one of countless other things
that binds our lives to the history of the
microcosmos and to the invisible forces that
cross all around this earth, things we humans have
found only by asking questions of the universe
and chasing down the many possible answers
until we find the next question.
Thank you joining us as we explore
the unseen world that surrounds us.
All of the names on the screen right now,
they are our patrons on Patreon.
They are people who decide, “Heck, I want
this thing to exist.
I think that it’s good.
I think that it’s lovely.
It makes me happy, brings me joy, and also,
it does those things for a lot of other people.
It brings joy and knowledge to the world and
I think it should exist.”
Cause it can’t exist without the support
of those people on the screen right now.
And if you’re interested in becoming one
of them, you can go to Patreon.com/JournytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there is
very  likely a subscribe button somewhere nearby.